The reviews are in for Ang Lee's sci-fi action
film Gemini Man, and they are… surprising.
The film stars Will Smith as a professional
killer who's inexplicably being pursued by
a younger version of himself and so far, most
critics are saying they enjoyed the visual
effects but found the story to be severely
underwhelming.
As you may recall, Twitter lit up with praise
for Gemini Man after the film was first screened
for critics in September.
"I make this look good."
But not so fast.
It looks like most critics who disliked the
film held off on sharing their opinions until
writing their actual reviews.
And unfortunately, it seems like most critics
fall directly into that category.
"No!
No!"
Sadly, yes.
The film which has been in development for
the better part of two decades struck most
reviewers as being all spectacle and no substance.
This is particularly surprising considering
that Ang Lee directed the film, and he has
numerous Academy Awards under his belt.
Over the years, he's demonstrated that he
can bring a special, decidedly human touch
to even the most CGI-heavy blockbuster.
Take 2003's Hulk, for example.
So what went wrong with Gemini Man?
Judging by the reviews, quite a bit.
Critics say the plot is too thin.
The characters are undercooked.
The dialogue induces groans galore.
And the central gimmick that is, the conflict
between the two Smiths ends up falling rather
flat.
In his two-star review, The Guardian's Peter
Bradshaw writes that,
"The digital novelty is striking for the first
10 minutes, silly for the next 10 minutes,
and by the end of the movie you're pining
for the analogue values of script and direction.
A wittier, smarter riff on everything could
have saved this."
As for Lee's decision to shoot the film at
a high frame rate, Bradshaw writes:
"[The technique] creates a new pin-sharp clarity
but at the expense of making the film look
like video or like a celluloid movie on a
plasma TV when you haven’t de-activated
motion smoothing.
It’s not a taste I want to acquire."
Variety's Peter Debruge was keen on reminding
everyone that Gemini Man spent several years
languishing in development hell and he suspects
there's a very good reason for that:
"[Gemini Man was] a nearly impossible project
to get made, […] falling through multiple
times because the technology wasn't there
yet.
At least, that's been the excuse, although
judging by the finished product, it was the
script that never lived up to the promise
of its premise."
If there's a common theme among the film's
many detractors, it's that Gemini Man will
likely be remembered as a fine technical achievement
that ultimately suffers from a supremely half-baked
script.
In the words of CNET's Richard Trenholm:
"It's genuinely impressive when Smith as we
know him goes face to face and even hand to
hand with the digitally de-aged mid-20s model.
[...] Unfortunately, it ends up as an unengaging
tech demo, because the characters and storyline
seem to have been given barely a fraction
of the thought that's gone into the effects."
Even some of the positive reviews take the
film to task for its lazy writing.
Abbie Bernstein of Assignment X writes that:
"[The film boasts] what is arguably the best
use of 3D since Avatar.
[...] This makes it all the more disappointing
to report that the screenplay […] is pretty
standard science-fiction fare.
It's moderately entertaining, but neither
director Lee's visual pizzazz nor the commitment
of the actors can keep the story from being
predictable and feeling familiar."
Blackfilm's Wilson Morales agreed:
"The story is not original but the visual
and action sequences rock.
[...] With so much time given the longevity
to getting greenlit, surely some of the money
spent on the technology could have gone to
the writers to punch up the script."
The Hollywood Reporter's Stephen Dalton was
particularly merciless in his review, writing
that
"The hyper-real look of Gemini Man is immersive
and richly detailed.
But it also has the disconcerting effect of
making a big-budget cinematic spectacle look
like a vintage videotaped TV drama.
To steal a line from Dolly Parton, it takes
a lot of money to look this cheap."
"I think I done just got mad."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.